[Music]
come on in come on in
it is so exciting to see all of you we
need to get everybody back in because
guess what I know a secret
and you know how it is I can't keep a
secret right
so how are you liking it so far yes
[Applause]
so what if our next speaker was somebody
pretty phenomenal
what if our next speaker was an
unshakable optimist
who really believes in a bright future
we can build together a truly Visionary
thinker with extremely rare intellect
who has devoted his career to advance
the vision of listen to this because
guys this speaks to us a world in which
the vast majority of people wake up
every single day inspired to feel safe
and at the end of the day fulfilled by
the work they do
good
what if our speaker was the author of
five best-selling books
what if one of them was start with y
what if one of them was Leaders Eat Last
what if one of them was the infinite
game
yes ladies and gentlemen help me welcome
Simon Senate
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you
so how exciting is this do you know when
they told me about this they told me
about this today because they knew I
couldn't keep a secret
okay so can I tell you a little bit
about our people
please
um
real estate people of course but I have
to tell you that you're in the presence
of truly servant leaders and what I mean
by that is they work every day to you
know help create a greater good which I
know you believe in for everybody truly
servant leaders that go out every day
and work on behalf of others I'm very
proud of them I'm very proud of several
things Simon number one our leadership
who during covid truly LED with with
calm
and you know it took us where we needed
to be we huddled we called a huddled and
these people came and they came again
and again and again and because of the
Huddle we called and because of what we
were able to do we really gave them the
charge to go into the community
and be a resource and not a sales pitch
and we did that a lot of different ways
we did that through helping to refuel
the um the food banks and how to look at
diversity from a different eye and how
to really go in and strengthen each
community that they could and and just
build a build a better life for people
and the result of that has been
tremendous growth in our company so I
wanted the opportunity to tell you that
just we don't get the recognition we
should typically as an industry we tend
to be commissioned breadth sometimes and
and that's not who we are we're an
entirely different company so we welcome
you and we're glad to have you here with
us today so talk to us a little bit
about the the fun things that might be
coming we know change is coming in our
industry we've had a really good ride
for a while
you talk about the infinite game if you
will first explain the difference in
infinite and finite games yeah sure
um I'm obsessed with this idea
um in the mid-1980s a philosopher and
theologian by the name of James karst
defined these two kinds of games finite
games and infinite games a finite game
is defined as known players fixed rules
and an agreed upon objective football
baseball there's always a beginning
middle and an end and if there is a
winner then necessarily there has to be
a loser
then you have infinite games infinite
games are defined as known and unknown
players which means anyone can join the
game at any time and you don't
necessarily know who all the other
players are
the rules are changeable which means
every player can play however they want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible turns out we are players in
infinite games every day of Our Lives
whether we know it or not there's no
such thing as winning Healthcare right
there's no such thing as winning
education you can come in first for the
finite amount of time you're at school
where we agree upon the time frame and
the metrics grades but nobody wins
education or nobody wins learning
um uh nobody you can't be number one in
your marriage it could be number two but
you can't be number one
uh uh uh well maybe the first time but
exactly exactly exactly but then it's
finite and you have to try again exactly
the goal is to perpetuate remember
um uh and there's definitely no such
thing as winning business
but if you listen to the language of so
many people it becomes abundantly clear
they don't actually know the game
they're playing in you know I hear
people all the time in business talk
about we're number one or I'm the best
you know or I want to beat my
competition
based on what based on what agreed upon
metrics objectives or time frames and
this is a problem because when we play
with a finite mindset in an infinite
game when we play to win in a game that
has no Finish Line
um then there is some consistent and
predictable outcomes the big ones are
the decline of trust the decline of
cooperation and the decline of
innovation and if you think about it
everything that I just described like
you don't know who all the other agents
are you don't you know anybody can
become an agent at any time they want
anybody can do their run their business
however they want and nobody wins you
can you know selling a property is
finite there's a beginning middle and
end okay that's what I was going to ask
you but then it just repeats and repeats
in a series of repeating infinite finite
games is doesn't make an infinite game
just makes you exhausted okay so we are
finite in ways because we have rules we
have guidelines we have all of that the
transactions are fine the try not yeah
and people come and go and enter and
mm-hmm now I'll give you a personal
example I want that that shows you the
differences do I want that that's the
question uh it's the good news is the
person who's who sold me this property
uh it was the seller's agent oh okay
right
um and
uh
he was charming and nice and wonderful
and lovely and helpful and all the
things that I would expect and I warmed
up to him and he was
apparently helping me and then I
remember distinctly at the closing
he sat there with no personality all of
his charm had left
all his friendliness had gone he barely
engaged with me he just wanted to be
there to collect his check so he could
get out of there
and I realized it was all fake it was
all for show it was all to butter me up
so that I would simply sign on the
dotted line and as a result I will never
work with him again as a buyer or a
seller
I'll never list with him ever and I
probably will never work with that
company again because I realized they
just saw me as a number they never saw
me as a person in the first place
um he was an old white guy I mean that
should tell you a little bit of
something as well that that sort of
maybe how he was raised in the industry
um and by the way the mortgage broker
was no different you know uh he was
charming and wonderful and lovely and
helped me get a great rate etc etc and
then I remember after I closed he called
me and said congratulations and I said
oh thank you that's so nice of you and
he called me just to congratulate me on
closing on my house and then the first
thing he said to me was and if you know
anybody who's looking for a mortgage I'd
really appreciate the recommendation he
never called me to congratulate me he
called me because he wanted the referral
like give it a breath
you know like call me and congratulate
me in a week later asked me for the
referral and see let me see what sucks
about that can I say that what sucks
about that totally is that's
that one person yeah colored your
entirely and but this is finite versus
infinite okay he he could only see the
transaction he could only see get
business get more business get business
get more business what he didn't
understand is he's dealing with a human
being and the more there's a
relationship I will gladly recommend him
I will gladly introduce you to my guy
right
um now I'm completely agnostic because
if you're going to treat me like a
transaction I'm going to treat you like
a transaction if you're going to treat
me like a transaction I'm going to
squeeze you to get more money out of you
I want a lower rate I'm going to squeeze
the agents but if you treat me like a
human being I'll gladly pay a higher
rate because I want to work with you and
that's what infinite minded players
understand better which you don't have
to be the cheapest you don't have to
have the lowest rate or the lowest price
if you have a great relationship
and you know thank you for saying that
and that really is we're the unbrokerage
you know we're the we're a little bit
untraditional I I just applaud you
saying that so let's
turn that just a little bit because I do
think the old mindset of real estate is
commission breath it's next next next I
want to say whatever I need to say do
whatever I need to do to get you on the
hook for the next time right what if
we looked at it from a consultant
perspective what if we said what the
consumer needs now because the summer
they've got all this stuff they can go
online and look at it they can do a
virtual tour they can go we can't be an
expert in what prices what what things
are worth anymore but yet they need a
navigator right now more than ever the
consumer needs a navigator so should we
approach it from a consultant or maybe
even a coaching perspective well I mean
the simple answer is yes how
um uh so let's think about what a coach
or a consult let's not use the word
consultant it's a dirty word in a lot of
Industries
um uh no no I don't mean that
disrespectfully it's just that um that
word has baggage can I tell you
something yeah my Tar Heels are in the
final game tonight so let's talk about
coaching
so so here's what I like about the term
coach more than consultant right
um a consultant
by the nature of the definition
it's I'm the expert I'm the consultant
right a coach recognizes that you you
are you have value so the best athletes
in the world have coaches
and by the way they're better than their
coaches at playing the game but the
coaches have a perspective that they
don't have
and so I'm a huge fan of the idea of
coaching and we say let me be your coach
doesn't diminish your your education in
fact you may have bought and sold more
houses than I've bought and sold you may
know more than me uh especially if
you're young in this industry and you're
selling to somebody this is not their
first rodeo
right but to be a coach means I'm going
to guide I'm going to do something heavy
lifting for you and you change your
style to meet the style of the person
you're with if they know a lot you can
speak to them at a different in a
different way please write that down the
definition of a coach if we go back
right a coach was to provide safe
Passage
right the coach would take you from
point A yeah and deliver you safely at
point B right that's what we do we find
your home
successful closing yep and I think one
of the essential
skills of being a good coach is
listening and this is a skill that is
not taught in school we don't learn it
on Home unfortunately and and we don't
learn it at work
listening is not hearing the words that
are spoken that's like my favorite quote
that you say go ahead I'm sorry
listening is
I thought I was being original
the the listening listening is not about
hearing the words that are spoken it's
not being able to Parrot back what
somebody said to you listening is
listening for meaning right
um you uh uh um you are a good listener
the tester being good at listener is if
the other person feels heard
right say that again right write that
down so so I mean we've all had we just
take it out of the context of business
right we've all had an argument or
wanted to share our feelings with a
friend or a loved one right spouse
girlfriend boyfriend you're sitting on
the couch and you say something's
bugging you and you say can I just tell
you something that's bugging me and they
respond by trying to fix it or they
respond by pointing out the facts that
may or may not align with how you feel
right well that's impossible because
this is what happened and what they're
missing is you are not looking for them
you're not looking for them to compare
the facts of what's being said you just
want to feel heard you just want
somebody to go oh my God that's really
hard yeah I hear it I hear that thank
you for sharing that with me that must
be difficult
all I needed right I'll give you a a a a
very funny example of bad listening so I
used to date a girl who's an air traffic
controller air attractive controllers
are breed unto themselves and it's only
about the facts and I woke up one
morning I had something in my eye and I
couldn't open my eye it was hurting and
I'm like flushing it out with water and
nothing's work and I mean I couldn't
even open my eyes to have her come on
like come here come here I'm gonna look
in my eye what did you see anything do
you understand anything and she looks in
she goes like this and she goes there's
nothing there and then walks away
and I eventually you know whatever it
was I eventually was okay and I went up
there I was like
WTF right
I'm like I had something in my eye you
just walked away
and she's like there was nothing there
so what do you want me to do
I was like a little sympathy she's like
well that's not going to get anything
out of your eye
listening is standing by my side while
I'm flushing it out with water and go oh
my God that must hurt so much yeah it
does thank you right that's listening
and if somebody can learn to listen and
now now this is where it gets actionable
this is not me just waxing philosophical
and telling funny stories about
listening my friend will gudero do how
many of you are
restaurant people have you ever heard of
11 Madison Park so at some point in New
York City 11 Madison Park was the best
rest restaurant in the world right
ranked number one and will believes in
this he's he was the former owner he
believes in this concept of unreasonable
Hospitality which is going to what good
services and then going way way way
Beyond and one of the core tenets of
unreasonable hospitality is learning to
listen and I'll give you an example that
directly impacts your business most
agents don't listen
and I'll give you an example what do you
do what do you do for your clients after
they close on a home right it's very
common we've all we've we've all bought
a home too right which is you walk into
this new home that you just bought as a
buyer and there's a bottle of champagne
in the fridge
there's a basket of flowers on the
dining room table
the same basket of flowers that you gave
to every other client the same bottle of
champagne that you gave to every client
generic I'm a number
it's just it's just rote but if you were
listening
while they were looking at all those
homes and they saw this one little room
that was too small to make a bedroom it
was just sort of a stupid little Nook
that nobody really understood why that
room existed in the house and your
client walked in and goes I could make
this my yoga room and that's the house
they bought instead of putting a bottle
of champagne in the house this is what
will talks about instead of putting a
bottle of champagne in the fridge why
not put a yoga mat in that room
with a little note that says it's
perfect right
that's called listening and every single
time you go out
[Applause]
every single time you go out with
clients
uh
they are telling you things they're
telling you stories they're waxing
philosophical they're telling you what
they don't like and what they do like
but the problem is you're listening to
whether they like big Windows you're
listening to whether they like the view
you're listening to whether they have
two cars and they need three cars or
whatever it is but you're not listening
to the reasons why the why you're not
listening for the meaning and that's
those the little notes you want to make
that make someone feel seen and make
someone feel heard and what will that do
for the referrals I mean you get
skyrocketed you get skyrockets because
you're no longer feeling like a number
you're feeling like a person
so we came through our industry
basically came through the pandemic
pretty well right I mean we've we've
been on an upward swing how many in here
believe change is coming a shift shift
happens right
um how do you feel about that
frightened
I heard even a very seasoned
professional say scared so how do we
deal with that
um
so
one of the things that I loved when
covid first showed up
was every talking head
talked about during these uncertain
times
and I wanted to write raise my hand and
be like
um all times are uncertain there's never
been a time ever that was certain
um
all that happened was something that we
didn't expect happened that reminded us
that time is uncertain and and periods
of consistency just breed laziness is
all they do
um uh when economies are skyrocketing
you can afford to be lazy people get bad
habits yeah you can afford to be you can
actually afford to be lazy when there's
no inventory and prices are Sky High and
all you have to do is show somebody one
house and they'll buy it tomorrow
like you're not a genius it's it's it's
not you
right
uh
it's like it's like somebody should have
leaned over and told Peloton you're not
better you're lucky right uh right place
right time
um and the Smart Ones know that the
Smart Ones don't take
um above average success I'll give you
the analogy so I know this guy who he he
trades stocks right and when the stock
market when he makes money he is it's
because he's a genius
when he loses money it's because of
market conditions right now you can have
it both ways you can't mix your Logics
you're either a genius or an idiot or
it's good market conditions and bad
market conditions but you can't mix them
right and the best people the ones with
the infinite mindset understand that
they understand they don't they don't
celebrate the good too much because they
understand that it can change tomorrow
and they don't mourn the bad too much
because they know it could change
tomorrow and it's about saving money and
being humble in the good times so that
you have money and remain confident in
the bad times it's the it's that
wonderful balance of humility and
confidence that go together but people
who make tons of money and spend it all
in good times have none in the bad times
and the best organizations the best
sales people the best solopreneurs I
know
they're they're they're they're
conservative in the in the in the good
times and they're liberal and the hard
times
it's so funny because that's the
calmness that we were led by we were led
by that exact mindset when the pandemic
first started
um
so the uncertainty the the just planning
just knowing let's pull that back to
coaching how do we take that out how do
we coach to that how are we coached to
that so uh the single best way to deal
with any kind of difficulty
personal struggle
business struggle Financial struggle
whatever it is
um is with others like no human being is
strong enough or smart enough to do this
thing called life or career alone we're
just not that we're just not that strong
but together
we're remarkable right
um
and so you know here we are talking
about relationships and listening as it
relates to buyers and sellers but the
reality is your ability to learn to
listen to deal with difficult
conversations to how to give and receive
feedback how to resolve conflict that's
actually as if not more important with
the people you work with the value of
this event by the way is not folks like
me on the stage this is this is just the
fun bits the value are the people you're
sitting next to the relationships you
build like during the breaks
during the breaks that's the important
stuff during the breaks don't disappear
just to be on your phone right because
like if you have a team back home and
you got to check all your email nothing
undermines trust in your team more than
you feel like you have to respond to
every single email that you're getting
just tell them you're going away to this
uh event deal with everything right
they're smart enough build them up but
putting that aside get to know the
people here because when bad things
happen
the single best resources you have is
each other right you can pick up the
phone and say I'm struggling
and it's it's doing it with each other I
I've had the the the the the the the the
big uh honor the huge honor of getting
to work with some of our folks in
uniform and not a single one of them
runs into battle for gutter country zero
uh it's always a person that's left in
person to the right and their courage
doesn't come from some deep internal
fortitude
comes from their desire to protect the
person next to them and the fear of
letting them down the fear of letting
them down is is worse than the fear of
some doing something difficult right
there was a former Navy SEAL
who was asked what kind of person makes
it into the seals right
and he said I can't tell you the kind of
person that makes it into the seals but
I can tell you the kind of person that
doesn't
he says uh he said the uh the Star
College athlete who's never really been
tested to the core of their being none
of those guys make it in
he said the preening leader that likes
to delegate everything none of those
guys make it in he said some of these
guys that show up with huge hulking
muscles covered in tattoos because they
want to prove how tough they are none of
those guys make it and he said some of
the guys who make it in are skinny and
scrawny he said some of the guys who
make it in you'll see them shivering out
of fear
he said but when they're emotionally
exhausted when they're physically
exhausted when they have absolutely
nothing left to give
somehow some way they're able to dig
down deep inside themselves to help the
guy next to them
in other words the highest performing
teams of the planet are not the
strongest or the smartest the highest
performing teams of the planet are the
ones who care the most and are willing
to sacrifice for the people next to them
that's you know I love that
and that that care and Community that's
a lot of our core our core values
they're two of our core values two two
of the C's so can we roll back just a
minute and go back to infinite game just
for a second because I hear you talking
about one of the principles in that yeah
building a trusting team and that is so
important in real estate it's not one
person that does anything every
successful person in this room has an
army of people working with them it
looks like a lender it looks like a
title company
um it looks like they're broker sure um
so talk about building that trusting
team so I'll give you an example first
of all what is a trusting team right
yeah we all know that trust is important
but what what is it really
um so I'll give you an example it's sort
of one of my favorite examples of what a
trusting team looks like so I a bunch of
years ago I was in Vegas for a business
trip and they were very nice to put me
up down the street at the Four Seasons
it's a beautiful hotel the four seasons
over here happens to have a coffee bar
in the lobby and so one afternoon I went
and bought myself a cup of coffee and
the the Barista working that day named
Noah he was charming and funny and
engaging and I stood there for far too
long talking to Noah
and as is my nature I asked Noah um
uh
do you like your job
without skipping a beat Noah said I love
my job
now in my line of work that's
significant like is rational right I
like the people I like the work I get
paid well I don't like my job love is
emotional it's a higher order connection
like do you love your wife I like her a
lot right
it's
right and Noah said I love my job so for
me I was like oh that's a higher ordered
a connection this kid's emotionally
connected to his job so immediately I
follow up and said can you tell me
specifically what the Four Seasons is
doing that you would even say to me I
love my job and again he didn't skip a
beat he said yeah throughout the day
managers will walk past me and ask me
how I'm doing ask me if there's anything
that I need to do my job better not just
my manager any manager and then he said
I also work at another hotel he says and
there the managers catch us when we're
doing things wrong he says they're the
managers who put pressure on us simply
to make our numbers and perform there I
like to keep my head below the radar and
just get through the day and collect my
paycheck only at the Four Seasons he
said do I feel there's that word again
do I feel I can be myself
what I find so profound about that story
is this is the exact same human being in
two different companies in two different
leadership environments and our
experience of him will be profoundly
different not because of the person but
because of the place he works right it's
not the person very often
and so uh you know when we talk about oh
you can't get good people these days I'm
like hmm
you know it's like the only common
factor in all my failed my relationships
is
right it's like if if there's no good
people ever that you can hire I'm
thinking there's one common factor in
all those people who are leaving you
that might be you
um and and and uh and and Noah's
experiences you know we have these we
have this Twisted a
thoughts about how we get the most out
of our people like how am I going to get
the most out of our mate people are not
a towel that you ring them out how much
you can get out of them you know the
question is what kind of environment can
I create in which my people can work at
their natural best and a trusting team
you know you're on a trusting team we've
all felt it you know you're on a
trusting team when you can raise your
hand and say
I don't understand
I don't know what I'm doing I need more
training I'm having struggles at home
it's affecting my work I'm scared I need
help without any fear of humiliation or
retribution but rather you say those
things with absolute confidence that
someone will rush in to support you we
also all know what it's like not to be
on a trusting team where you do not
admit mistakes you did not admit you
don't know what you're doing you never
ask for help and you spend most of your
days lying hiding and faking yeah which
works for a short period of time but
eventually cracks become you know the
cracks start to grow and things start to
break
trusting teams are feeling safe
to ask for help that's what a trusting
team is and you're either on one or
you're making one you know it's so
interesting because
then I tell you my Tar Heels are in a
national championships yes
congratulations um well
they were just not even predicted to go
to the go to the tournament and there's
a story about them that in the at the
beginning of December I mean they were
terrible and they had a big loss and
they came back to the university and
they got off the bus and they went in
the locker room and they stayed together
until three o'clock in the morning
because they said we have the skill
right we we know the game we have the
skill we're conditioned what they didn't
have was trust right and they came out
of that at three o'clock in the morning
and they worked it out yeah that
collaborative thing of saying and I
don't even think the coach was there I
think it was just you know you meet
heads need to go in there and figure
this out and they did and the result has
been winning since then so what do we
need to do if we form that team if we're
you know clearly all of these people are
in the right company
um but but how do we how do we clear
that how do we how do we build that
trust or is that a really big topic
that's a very big topic but it's no
different than how you build trust in
any kind of relationship so you say I
I've met this person that I really like
how do I build trust well you don't tell
them all your secrets on the first day
right we all know that you have to be
vulnerable but but there is there is a
there's a timing you know and it's a
dance and it's and it's giving somebody
a little extra
responsibility and seeing how they do
and if they screw up instead of yelling
at them be like all right try again you
know that we treat mistakes as learning
opportunities rather than you know and a
mistake is only when you keep repeating
the same error and you haven't learned
anything
um
um where we practice empathy you build
trust with empathy as well so
um uh empathy uh in business looks like
this
um here's a traditional
scenario
um
somebody walks you know picks up the
phone or walks into their office when we
had when we did that
um and says um
you know your numbers are down for the
third quarter in a row
um
we've had this conversation before and
if you don't pick up your numbers in the
fourth quarter I don't know what's going
to happen right that's pretty normal
here's empathy injected into that
scenario hey your numbers are down for
the third quarter in a row we've had
this conversation before
um are you okay I'm worried about you
what's going on WOW right where it's
about the person not the performance
and so when again it goes back to that
listening and you you are not listening
until somebody else feels heard
those things you know seeing someone as
human understanding that we all have
stresses and strains and Egos and
insecurities and we bring all of that to
work
and though we still have to be uh
emotionally professional you know you
can't sit in a meeting like this because
you're having a bad day that's
emotionally unprofessional
um though we still have to be
emotionally professional
um we're still human beings yeah
um and a good leader uh recognizes that
and by the way somebody on a team
recognizes that too you don't have to be
a position of authority to be a good
leader you know because those who may be
higher in rank than us are also filled
with insecurity and fear and stress and
strain and the ego and all that right
and it's okay to go up the chain of
command and say hey are you okay you
know you were really hard on us in that
meeting today instead of labeling them
an be like are you are you okay
you know and and by the way and that's
the dance it's like any relationship you
know it's not expected for one person in
an interpersonal relationship to to do
all the listening it's a dance and it
goes backwards and forwards and you know
you you you you meet empathy with
empathy and you meet listening with
listening and and you meet difficult
conversations with difficult
conversations I think that's been such a
lesson for us in covid with people
working remotely is that hearing is one
of the five senses but listening is an
art where you really have to you have to
look at body language and you have to
figure out what's going on that's more
than what is Right Here Right which we
missed out on covid yeah like somebody's
somebody's sitting there you know and
like they're talking and they're
bouncing their leg like this because
they're nervous you miss that you missed
that on Zoom yeah because you know you
get nothing yeah so can we talk about
one of rivalry yeah
so of the five practices of the infinite
game or an internet mindset having a
worthy rival is the easiest one to
implement immediately
so in a competition in a in a finite
game baseball football you have
competitors to be beaten right
um but in an infinite game they come go
they do whatever they want you don't
have competitors because you're not even
playing by the same rules but you do
have Rivals and some of those Rivals are
worthy of comparison
and a worthy rival is someone who does
probably similar things as you who does
one or many things
better than you
in fact their name might make you angry
okay right
um the mirror utterance of somebody goes
ah she's the best and you're thinking
not that
and you're smiling but that's not what
you're thinking that's probably someone
who's your worthy rival because their
strengths are making you insecure their
strength are revealing to you your
weaknesses and that's what a worthy
rival does a worthy rival their
strengths reveal to you or weaknesses
and you don't have to like them but you
do have to respect them and thank them
because the goal is not to beat them the
goal is to improve yourself the only
true competitor in the infinite game is
yourself
and see where that is so tough for our
industry is
cooperation right and what I mean by
that is I may be competing against you
for a listing yep but I win the listing
I might need you to sell a house so
we're competing but there's got to be
that cooperation along with it and a
finite mindset is everything is about
this transaction this listing an
infinite mindset is I may win or lose
this game I may win or lose this
transaction and there'll be another one
and another one and another one and
another one and the goal is not to win
this one the goal is to be better and
better and better and better and better
and what happens is you win more often
yeah so I I uh see and where I struggle
with that honestly is I want to crush it
every time yeah of course of course
you're a highly competitive A type
personality I get it yeah
um
but if that's all you do you you're not
going to be in the game no I can I've
been in a long time but this is my point
infinite in the infinite game
the infinite game the infinite mindset
is about having the strength the will
and the resources which we will is I
really still enjoy this industry
and the resources I got the money to
stay in the game if you run out of will
you run out of resources you find a
different line of work right the goal is
not to win every game the goal is to
stay in the game as long as possible and
you're more likely to stay in the game
as long as possible if you're enjoying
it and if you're making money
so uh but like I said think of those
agents who are better than you whether
they're better marketers or better
salesperson or they have they get more
recommendations and again you don't have
to like them you have to thank them and
study them and learn what they're doing
as I said because their strengths are
revealed revealing to your weaknesses
and sometimes partner with them because
you're actually stronger together
but hating them is
stupid right
all it does is make you cut focus on
them rather than focus on yourself all
it does is make you focus and and sit
around with your friends and be like but
they don't do this and they well you're
not doing any of that either you know so
it puts all your focus in all the wrong
places
it's like you know what it's like uh uh
if the any skiers out there if you ski
through trees
every skier knows this if you say don't
hit a tree don't hit a tree don't hit a
tree you hit a tree
because all you're doing is looking at
trees
where when you're skiing through cheese
and you say follow the path follow the
path follow the path you don't hit a
tree because you're only looking at the
path so your mindset is if all you're
doing is focusing on them then you're
good you're hitting trees is what you're
doing you're focusing all the things
that make you weak rather than focusing
on all the things that make you better
so focus on the positive right
I really I love the concept of us being
coaches
and as getting people to that that safe
place yeah and train people to be
coaches you know we teach people how to
sell but we don't teach people how to
coach
wow and they're both skills they're both
learnable practical skills
I love the art of listening you know I
think that is just going to transport
you to another level
in production and referrals and and all
of that
you know there's a great irony you know
the companies that I know that teach
listening to their people so that they
will be better leaders better sales
people whatever it is
the profound impact it has on someone's
life
the you know they report back that thank
you for teaching me that listening
skills that I could be a better
salesperson my marriage is better my
relationship with my kids is better you
know my relationship with my parents is
better because the the art of listening
is applicable everywhere where you
interact with another human being not
just at work even though the company
taught you that skill for work and my
biggest fear because we don't need to go
down that rabbit hole but my biggest
fear is screens are taking that away
correct
yeah I mean I can prove it to you and by
the way I've I've had this happen with
agents
can I borrow someone's phone Joe can I
just borrow a phone yeah thanks
I know it's okay here I'll get one
there you go
okay I just want to show you something
I'm just going to show you a little I'm
just gonna
okay I'm just going to show you
something right so
um
I'm just holding my phone
while I'm talking to you guys uh it's
not buzzing it's not beeping I'm not
checking it I'm just holding it let me
just ask you a question do you feel like
you're the most important thing to me
right now
exactly there's a deep-seated
psychological reaction when you were
walking around a house with a client
holding your phone even if you're not
checking it
and I have absolutely had it where I've
been walking around with an agent and
they're talking to me and then I like
look to the left and I turn around and
they're like this
guess how that made me feel
that I am not the most important thing
to that person in this moment wow right
and this and this is artificial I'm just
doing it right now in front of a room
and I'm not even looking down and you
don't feel that special right
so uh the point is is put your phone
away for the 10 minutes you're walking
around a house
and you go ahead
uh the
[Applause]
I mean like like the the art of making
someone feel seen and heard is stupidly
simple
right uh learning their name really
quickly is really easy
and calling them by their name is really
easy asking them questions not about
what they're looking for in a house but
asking questions about who they are like
where they see themselves in five years
professionally like you know are you
married or single what do you know what
do you learn about them as if you know
as people
and all of that learning
makes you show people different things
it makes you it makes you creative I
know this wasn't the kind of house you
were looking for but based on what we
talked about before I think you'll
really like this and now you're not
looking to sell them a house you're
looking to sell them a home and I know a
lot of you use those terminology I'm not
here to help you find a house I'm here
to find a home and yet you still left a
bottle of champagne in the in the fridge
in their new house
you didn't help them make a home with a
yoga mat
um uh so uh really really easy put put
your devices away because not only does
it distract us but as an act of service
um you're doing it for someone else now
if you have an emergency you simply
apologize my mother's in the hospital I
have to keep my phone and I'm terrified
really sorry I will try my best not
totally fine but uh you don't get to use
that card very often that is the
exception not the rule yeah and it's a
transaction that you're waiting for does
not count
it'll have to wait 15 minutes
and you know Kuba tells us that all the
time just create that amazing experience
right and and that's what you're doing
because that makes you memorable that's
going to set you apart from your
competitors that one act of intention I
can so
when they were building Disneyland
the imagineers took Walt Disney on a
tour
to show them what they had built they
showed them one of the rides I can't
remember which one and they built an
animatronic bird
perfect in every detail
and they showed it to Walt it's so
excited for him to be to show them this
perfect perfect animatronic bird that no
guest would ever be able to tell the
difference between this and a real bird
and Walt looks at and goes
no it's it's not it's not going to work
and they're like Walt it's perfect in
every detail it's the feathers of the
color it's the movement every perfect in
every detail and Walt said the bird's
not breathing
and they said no one will notice and he
said people can feel perfection
and that's the point which is they may
not be able to say the thing that you
did or did not do but they can feel it
wow
that's great that's powerful
[Applause]
so one thing that I'm extremely proud of
and I'm not sure everyone in here is
aware of it but we have we are aware of
our core values which I shared with you
and our Manifesto which I shared in our
six C's which is what everything we do
we're driven by that we bounce up
against that but we've introduced be
golden be you and I was so excited to
introduce this to you because it speaks
so much to who you are and the golden is
growth and it's not grow that I'm I'm
going to beat you by growing it's you
know that internal growth its own so
have extreme ownership in what you do
um it's law it's love the L is love and
Cuba is very driven by come from your
heart be genuine which is what you're
saying you knew the realtor was faking
it right so come from your heart
everything should be driven by love be
determined
which you know be intentional be
determined with everything you do
practice equality
so treat everyone better than you want
to be treated and I think the diversity
of our Network and I'm not going to say
family because family can be so
dysfunctional right but our team of our
organ
you know if your family's not
dysfunctional you may not know them all
um but but but practice that if I'm just
maybe that was too personal
um but that equality of of loving one
another and then to do it now you know
to make sure that we don't know how much
time we have we we don't know
um but just be intentional so I'm really
proud of that I'm proud to talk to you
about that I'm proud for that behavior
to be who we become you know who we grow
into as an organization
yes I like things that are verbs I like
things that are behaviors more than just
sort of you know I I believe that value
should be written as verbs you know you
go to so many companies and they have
the values written on the wall you know
you know Integrity you know
Innovation right with the big yeah yeah
Innovation honesty you know if you have
to write honesty on the wall you've got
bigger problems but the the
the like Innovation is not a value you
can't walk into somebody's office and
say a little more Innovation today
please like what are they supposed to do
right uh but if you want to put
Integrity you write do the right thing
if you want to do honesty you say tell
the truth if you want to say Innovation
say look at the problem from a different
angle like they make them be make them
behaviors that people can do
um so I'm a great book so I like
behaviors I like that you did that
um the concept of treating people the
way you want to be treated I'm not sure
I agree with that one okay have that
better than you want to be treated I
think treat people the way they want to
be treated okay
you know because
you win you win and by the way that's
that's that's and that that goes both
ways right some people want a lot of
attention give them a lot of attention
some people want little very little
attention don't bug them right and so
you you know uh treating people is a
dial and you can tell the ones that have
a formula because they're not listening
you know like when somebody's giving me
a pitch and I'm like looking the other
direction and I'm like glazing over and
they're still talking
it's because they have to get through
the script and they're completely
ignoring the room they're completely
ignoring the fact that I am just not
interested and so in an instant people
can feel perfection in an instant I've
come to the conclusion in a span of 30
seconds that this person has no interest
in me they have an interest in getting
through their script which means they're
interested in getting through their
transaction and I've already formed an
entire judgment an entire opinion oh
what this relationship is going to be
like and if you treat me as a
transaction I treat you as a transaction
which means I got 18 agents working for
me not just you because that's how you
treated me that's why I'm treating you
I'll play by your rules if you treat me
with love and make me feel I don't want
to work with anybody else
right so if you're just trying to get
the most money out of me then I'm going
to try and get the least money out of
somebody else
so uh uh and again people will play by
the rules that you set I'm guessing that
I thing didn't work out well is that
what the thing in your eye that she
didn't help you that I'm guessing that
didn't work well when I when I talked to
her afterwards I sort of didn't finish
the story I went up to her I was like
you know you can show me a little
sympathy and you know she said well
that's not going to help you get
anything out of your eye I mean and
that's sort of how she thinks about
everything and she God bless her she had
to learn that relationships are not
based on facts and figures and that is
true in business as it is in a
relationship which is the facts don't
always matter it's how I felt that I
feel supported in that moment and how so
you do want to be treated and how I do
it don't treat me the way you would
because she doesn't want because she
treat me the way I want to be treated
I'm sensitive yeah got it okay
got it thank you so questions are we
okay to do some questions anybody got
questions I think we've got microphones
don't be shy
there will be a follow-up to that so be
careful
yeah
I knew that
questions
and he is wisely not answering that
question by the way mainly because I
don't know what to say after
hi Simon what an honor it is by the way
my name
thank you and Kathy
um my question is you speak a lot to us
you write tons of books I'm an
association leader as well as someone
who serves 370 agents directly on a
daily basis and it's really easy to take
it in and like hear it while you're
saying it sure but how would you suggest
people actually go home and reflect and
the points you've made today to better
themselves
uh great question so you know pick one
thing and go do it you know it's it's
kind of like anything which is you know
you know when you learn to drive a car
fly a plane you know sell a house
whatever it is it's overwhelming that's
so much information
and you can't be expected to learn it
all and practice it all tomorrow it's
it's a journey it's a process and so you
know do these things out loud do these
things live
um and practice them and I'll go back to
one of the things that I said before
with someone you know if anybody's ever
gotten their scuba certification they
teach you don't go diving by yourself
you have to have a dive buddy right
because it's safer right you don't do it
by yourself it's actually stupid
um uh and and I think that's what this
journey is you should have a leadership
buddy because it's too hard to do by
yourself and it's too overwhelming and
Leadership is very often a very lonely
position
because as you make your way up the
ranks you gain some success it's harder
and harder to know who you could be
completely vulnerable with you can't
come to work and be like
it's not going to work I'm not I don't
know I can't no you know it's like you
can talk about being stressed you can
talk about that it's a hard time you can
talk about being uncertain
but you can't just break down but you
have to break down you have to break
down to someone
and so you've got to have a leadership
buddy because the leadership buddy will
be there to hold you in your darkest
moments and give you a space to let it
all out but at the same time they're
there when you need to make difficult
decisions saying you got this I believe
in you
um and that'll give you the card to do
it so um who's your leadership buddy
well that's amazing
you're welcome you're welcome
hi Simon Denise Pollock San Diego
um earlier uh Ben was speaking about
bucket lists and you know let's say you
put a hundred items on there
where do you start what do you do how do
you do it you know to prioritize you
know like one we were talking over here
one of my bucket list long-term items is
to buy a huge star-worthy RV and drive
across the you know country which I know
is not attainable in this moment but how
do we start with a hundred things you
know to a married life okay I'm gonna
get in trouble now right because I don't
believe in bucket lists
uh because I believe in Reverse bucket
lists
oh I'm gonna like this keep going uh
what a bucket list does is a long list
of things that we haven't done and it
reminds us of all the things we're
missing
and it it neglects gratitude
and I would rather we look at all the
things we have done
uh and be grateful for the fact that
we've lived Rich lives up until this
moment
and
uh
and so are are there dreams that I have
of course are the things I want to do of
course do I know what some of them are
in my head of course
do I hope to check them off that list of
course
court but what's more fun to do is go
through the list of things I have done
and the things that I never thought I
would be able to do that I was able to
do
and it it's a nicer feeling than the
things I'm missing out on
and for you can I can I
act I know what I'm talking about sure
okay that's um I've made a whole career
out of it okay
um see I wish you would just pause and
maybe look back at the lives you've
changed through through the work you're
doing because you're changing lives
every day I mean you're creating amazing
memories for families and and all of you
need to do that you're you're making a
big difference and I'll add to that I'll
see your raise and I'll raise you
uh uh and be specific
like it's not enough to say you help so
many families just think about all the
families you have like tell me what
their name is
like actually think of the actual family
right the more you can connect it to a
real human being
the more you will feel it
um and I'll prove it to you
Stalin said
Stalin said the death of
uh one man is a tragedy in the death of
a million as a statistic
right so
I'll tell you two stories both are true
um
right now what we are witnessing in
Europe is a horrible event of this war
in Ukraine and we see a proud people
standing up to defend themselves
against this oppressive regime that is
invading their country unnecessarily
and the conservative
estimates now are you know uh I I think
the last one I read was about you know
five thousand
men and women killed rising up against
the despotic regime right
that's a fact those are numbers now let
me tell you another story
I have a friend named Cami who
um lives in San Clemente California and
she was driving home from work one day
and she
as she turned the corner She Came Upon a
car accident that had just happened
um where a 17 year old driver had hit an
18 year old pedestrian
and this 18 year old girl was lying on
the street her leg at a 90 degree angle
unconscious and the ambulances hadn't
arrived yet
Cami pulled her car over and got out and
sat with the girl and just sat with her
until the paramedics arrived
eventually the paramedics arrived and
took her away
and a few days later she was curious
what happened to that girl she went
online onto the blotter and found out
that that 18 year old girl had died
okay what made you feel more
thousands of people who died standing up
against the oppressive regime to defend
their lifestyle and their democracy or
one 18 year old girl who got hit by a
car in California
that's my point which is when you tell a
story about a specific person you feel
it way more
than telling statistics of all the
people you held helped or all the homes
you've sold I don't care about how many
homes you've sold or how many families
you've helped tell me about the one you
remember
you know that's the one you tell and
when somebody says what can you do for
me I've lived in this neighborhood for
30 years and I have a greater knowledge
of this neighborhood than anybody else
and I've sold more houses and I'll get
you the best deal and then you get a
cynical bastard like me who goes your
business model encourages you not to get
me the best deal
I mean that's the way I think I
apologize because you want to keep the
price up because that's what makes you
more money like I know like I get it
right it's like therapists don't want to
get you better because they get paid by
the hour
um
uh if they did flat feet we'd all be
fine
[Music]
but if you if you walk in and say if
somebody says why should I why should I
do business with you
right you'd be like three years ago I
met this family
the Joneses oh what a wonderful couple
two kids Lucy and George and just the
best and and you tell a story about what
you got to know about them and what they
were looking for and how you spent the
time with them and people will relate
their experience to the Joneses not to
the 55 houses you've sold over the 30
years you've been in business because I
don't care
I just need one
and so the more you can tell a specific
Story the more people can feel it
to yourself and to others
that is powerful
and now you can go back and use what you
can people say what'd you learn at the
at the conference you'd be like well
Stalin said
can I tell you one more thing and brag a
little bit
you're not related to staliner no okay
um one thing that we've done as an
organization I'm extremely proud of this
Cuban Luba have been very touched by the
Ukraine situation and what a couple of
weeks ago maybe a month and a half ago
Cooper they decided I think with the
girls I'm making this up so forgive me
they decided it may be true they decided
with their girls that they wanted to do
something to make a difference for the
kids in Ukraine and this tiny little
idea for us to go out and fill shoe
boxes with toys and things for the
children resulted six weeks later in
over 31
000 shoe boxes that have been shipped to
Poland wow what I wish is that we knew
those kids that received it to be able
to model what you're saying but very
proud of this group just very very much
how committed that's beautiful we are in
that wonderful that's magical yeah see
and that's the kind of story you don't
hear about Realtors
you don't
and can I make it better over here Janet
um let me make it let me just and all of
you don't know this
and God love them they're from Kansas
but I know I know um but let me tell you
this story because a lot of you may not
know this story
um Janet's office her office one of our
one of her competitors her rivalries
there is Keller Williams and I might be
making this up too so forgive me I might
be embellishing a little bit but the
Market Center there called and said can
we contribute to the shoebox drive and
so 80 60 80 125 shoe boxes they
contributed from the from the Market
Center one of their agents was Ukrainian
and she hand wrote prayers oh beautiful
to go in the shoe boxes beautiful and
you I don't want to start crying you
don't
um you don't hear that you don't hear
that that's how our industry works yeah
you just hear the commission breath
right so
guys go out there make a difference
you've got a lot of power
that's great next question I think we
got time for maybe one more one or two
more Scott
thank you Cuba my name is uh Todd
fallman from the Seattle area uh thank
you Cuba thank you Kathy and special
thanks Simon for spending some time with
us uh in terms of pursuit of infinite
growth and value uh how would you define
the difference between passion and
purpose and how would that help lead us
in that experience
uh passion is an output
uh
purpose is an input
we always talk about I you know I'm
passionate for this I'm like
I mean like everybody's passionate for
something you know passion's an output
like you know it's like I love talking
to people like we only hire passionate
people well how do you know that the
passion of your interviewing not so
passionate for working right the so I
always think that passion is an output
which is when you are doing something
that you believe in
when you're doing something that feels
like it's bigger than yourself that you
feel like you're contributing to a
larger purpose what you feel is Passion
like working hard for something that we
love is called passion working hard for
something we don't love is called stress
um it's an output it's not an input
purpose is like is like a battery right
it provides energy and so in fact I was
just talking backstage about this before
I came out which is which is when I set
out to spread my message
uh there was some personal sacrifice
that I had to make I was traveling a lot
which means there was a lot of physical
exertion and exhaustion
um I it took a huge hit to my personal
life you know I'd go on a first date and
be like oh my God this is amazing are
you free in six weeks for a second date
you know
um
um because I met this girl in Vegas at
this conference is amazing
that was a shout out
[Applause]
uh but the point is is because I had a
sense of purpose though I did not enjoy
it it was worth it
so I think purpose makes us feel like
the sacrifices we're making are worth it
and uh and you'll know it because what
you feel is Passion it's an input and an
output
I guess better put you need purpose to
feel passion
that would be a nicer way of saying it
that is one of those things that's kind
of get hard to get your head around
though right
or not you but I'm just oh the rest of
it I don't think I don't think you need
passion to feel purpose because what
you're saying is then you have to have
energy before before you can have
belonging and I don't believe that but
you need purpose to feel passion you
need to feel like your work
contributes to something bigger than
simply buying and selling houses
you know you need to feel like you're
contributing something bigger than
yourself uh
um and and when you feel like the days
you don't feel like working and you meet
that one person that it all sudden it's
like having kids like you know
rationally speaking I don't know why
anyone would want to have a child right
um I mean you don't get to go on
vacation when you want to go on vacation
you can only go on vacation when they
have school I have no school you know
dinner was macaroni and cheese from a
plastic spoon over the sink like
sleeping is something you abandoned for
a couple of years you know you give up
your life you your your marriage is very
very different than it was
um and your entire life is consumed by
children for many many many years
and it's
frustrating and hard and stressful
um but that one time you catch your
five-year-old sharing with your
four-year-old
unexpectedly or when you go to make sure
your eight-year-old is sleeping and you
catch her underneath the blankets with a
flashlight reading
you know or the first school player the
first boyfriend or girlfriend or
girlfriend or whatever when they get
into all of that sacrifices instantly
worth it
and so I think when we weigh the the
rational side of it we'd never do
anything that required hard work or
sacrifice but when we're contributing to
the life of someone else and we get to
see that life Thrive and grow all of a
sudden sacrifice becomes worth it and
that's what I think purpose is it's the
knowledge that our that our
contributions will live on outside of us
forever like it's not that you just did
something nice for someone it's that
they will carry that feeling and make
them a better person you know in their
own lives in other words you live
forever through the lives of others
and with children it's grandchildren yes
unfortunately you have to have the
children to get the grandchildren yeah I
mean and then when you have
grandchildren then you get to have
Revenge that's it
that's it maybe one more and then we're
done
oh this is going to be good because I
know this guy this is going to be good
all right Simon my name is John Myers
I'm from Wilmington North Carolina
um
oh it's gonna be a great game tonight
I'm glad you're here because when I
first met Kathy one of the books that I
talked about have defined who I was was
start with why and today you talk about
listening and how important that is and
understanding someone's story
if you had to choose one question that
you could ask someone to help
figure out their story what would it be
uh
so the question that I ask is I ask
people where they're from
I mean I I ask people about their
childhood I mean I want to know people
where people are from and I don't mean
where they were born
you know I'm like tell me about who you
are where you come from and because
people can
you know the future is
figments of our imagination
um
asking people about what they do now
they'll tell you what they want you to
hear
but when you ask somebody where they
come from and tell me a tell me a happy
story tell me a happy memory from when
you were a kid
they can only remember the things that
matter you know we've forgotten most of
the things that we did when we were kids
but we remember the things that mattered
um and so those things tend to be
incredibly objective so when I'm really
trying to get to know somebody I want to
go backwards not forwards and I don't
want to talk about the present
it's powerful
[Applause]
I let do that eyebrow thing again I
don't know what I did
your eyebrow almost parted your hair on
that side you looked at me and your
eyebrow went up that was that was nice
um
these days my eyebrow has to go higher
and higher
this has been such an honor it's such an
honor to introduce you to This
Magnificent group of people and just I'm
so thrilled that you poured into them
what you did there's so many nuggets
that they can go back and apply today to
the business they're doing so we
appreciate you I'm going to say be
golden be you because that's who we are
guys Simon says thank you very much